thank you alejandro levon welcome back
uh to the studio at the beginning of the
broadcast i did mention your game as a
highlight at least for me because you
said that you're looking for revenge
after the american cup did the strategy
change at any point or when in in the
game during the game did that strategy
change if at any point uh
yeah i think uh
somehow i didn't really go the way i
expected in the opening i was thinking
to
you know get something
more playable
without revealing too much you started
off with the bishop's opening did you
want to avoid the the petrov or what was
the
main
i wanted to have a surprise just have a
surprise get a game yeah yeah and then i
think
yeah somehow i really forgot what i was
intending to do in this bishop before
stuff because well
there's so many
other moves i mean a5 is very popular
and uh
and there was a game played here already
in this event yes
you flying on black yeah
so
yeah i remembered uh
i remembered that i thought that maybe
this is playable but then i forgot that
i actually played uh a game like this
against pogba already he did in a blitz
game he did yeah and he actually it
seems like he played quite a couple of
times against magnus himself and uh
one of the main proponents and it seems
like you also play the game with the
black pieces against nepal did you
remember that yet actually not
no i just well honestly i didn't think
that uh fabiano is going to go for this
but we'll play something else and then
uh
yeah i thought
okay
the principle was to take ed but
i couldn't really see what's what's
great with my position and here okay
knight g3 is kind of a little try
because rookie one bishop f5 is finished
it's totally drawn
but uh yeah queen d6 i think just with
two draw and it's not like i was
you know
so keen to play something risky or
something i just thought that i should
give a little try and things don't work
i'm in a good situation and well i'm
playing white which is the new black
we discussed that yesterday and the
black has the new white so i
you know i have to play solid speaking
of that you're actually going to have a
very difficult uh game tomorrow against
nepo himself the challenger for the
world crown last year uh are you in any
way shape or form fearful of let's say
his preparation at all or i'm fearful of
everybody
okay that's the way you're supposed to
be and when you're fearful you feel like
you're playing better chess
when i'm more conservative or well the
thing is i'm so
self-confident that from time to time i
have to
force myself to be fearful
and i think this this is a lesson i
learned from
mike tyson because he said uh
because
he had the same
approach he was very
self-confident so i had to remind myself
that i can get knocked out every second
and that was keeping me from you know
flying in the in the sky and thinking
he's invisible so you have to remember
that your opponents are very good
and
that's
if you're a very confident guy like me
or mike tyson and then things will work
perfect levon well you're most likely
going to go into the last couple of
rounds as the co-leader unless wesley
pulls off a miracle today uh stay away
from the knockout and we'll see you in
uh tomorrow thank god guys back to you
thank you christian uh thank you lavon
always interesting interviews with
lavonne quoting that uh sage sage of our
days yeah
mike nice to meet you and